excuse me man can you help
me we follow me to my
house wait here for a
moment
I need you to help me find this my T I
need to go
[Music]
back for your
[Applause]
sacri it's awfully squanky in here
welcome to crowded followed there's
something following you you're not
paranoid it's
there no one else sees it but it's there
following you wherever you go wherever
you
are it's always
following I think I'm quoting the plot
of it falls I've never actually seen it
but this is a game where you're being
followed I
think I have
$3.40 sure is cold tonight that it
is do I why do I have a breath
bar oh no why do I have a breath por
although it's nice to get out of that
Subway every now and then gets tiring
sitting all day asking strangers for
change 340 is all I got today not much
but it should keep me going for now I
must try and get some sleep
soon well that was Ill timed what the
another shooting the city is getting out
of hand well I should probably have a
look should I should I I do that is that
what
I all
right well I
looked and I kind of regret
it
yep oh boy oh boy uh hey what's up um
you're right where hell am oh what I
missed that one this ain't good you
listen you got to take this please don't
let it take the case I feel like there's
a bit of a misunderstanding here be
careful it might take the form of
someone else I'm
sorry it's
[Music]
here wait a
minute oh my God are you actually
getting closer I don't see anything I
see nothing I don't see anything I don't
see it whatever you do seeing it is not
what I'm doing I don't see I don't even
have eyes I don't ever have eyes I
wasn't born with any ocular
nerves all right so does this thing have
a gun is that is that what the is is
that what the deal is
that uh
hi no no no no
okay oh okay only we can see it now you
need to get out of here there Subway
down the alley get the last train now
okay whoa I was going the wrong way all
right so um
uh so good good good this is
fine this is fine who had the
gun and why had the
gun why have gun oh oh hey bud hi oh man
that's different that's that's
definitely different that's something I
haven't that's different that's a little
different okay you let see oh boy that's
oh I got it what but but I have it I did
it
hi hello who was that luckily I was able
to get this last train I'll get off on
the last stop and find some somewhere to
rest up for the night what's so
important about this case I already
tried to open it but it won't
budge who's back there who's who you I
try to force it open when I get the wait
where the where did I put my ticket I
must have dropped it when I was running
away I'm going to need to get it through
the exit although I'm a bit short on
funds right
now oh
hi that light is good timing how can no
one else see it it doesn't matter got to
get out of the station
okay oh oh oh oh oh oh man you tall okay
all right okay whoa ah okay all right
hey uh anybody got uh some uh
money EXC excuse me excuse
me oh
boy okay I don't have any money okay I
don't have money no money no my
oh B I'm looking don't push me don't
push me nothing of Interest sure it's
fine
oh what's that on the ground that looks
important money okay oh that's not
enough okay um do I ever recover my
stamina I do a little bit well looks
like he's gone for
good good thing he's
tall I see right I see I see how this is
going to be oh boy okay well all right
this is great get out of my way hey
don't mind if I do you got money got
money money money money money anything
in the vending machines money money hope
I don't spend this
money how close are
you it's
fine oh oh boy okay well if I look this
way I can keep an eye
out all right that's good money oh stop
it stop it stop it stop it stop where
why who what I don't see I
see oh I'm going to run out of
stamina oh a coin dispenser this got to
have some
goodies okay he's getting faster isn't
he that that seemed kind of quick I
don't like that I got to get some
distance okay coin machine
please
okay just going to I know I'm running
low on stamina but you know just going
to nothing nothing damn oh I missed that
coin machine where was it under bench
sure a sweet well that's not good that's
not good you're way closer than you
should be oh I'm going to run out of
stamina oh boy is this different I don't
remember any of
this coin Locker yeah
sure oh boy oh boy oh boy ohy oh boy
excuse me pardon me pardon me pardon
me already searched that
[Music]
one okay that's not good hey
coins excuse me I just need a little
more oh come
on okay yeah I don't have any stamina
anymore so I'm in trouble I'm get please
I why are you why would you be like this
oh no oh oh no oh no oh no no oh no oh
no oh no no oh why do you have to be
slightly faster than
me I don't think it's good for my
stamina if I scream when I run but oh
boy I'm doomed I'm doomed I'm doomed oh
boy oh Glory oh good oh good please give
me give me I'm I can't I'm dead I'm dead
man I'm a dead man I'm a dead
man well that was bad okay I well the
thing is I didn't know that I needed to
start off searching get out of the way
please please please
[Music]
please search search and then run search
search
run get some distance cut the corners be
real smooth about it good
it's definitely not
here definitely not here scoot so I'm
scooting I should search and move at the
same time there's probably definitely a
way probably definitely is a way to do
that searching and walking I can do
that take some skill kit stop
please please oh you're so much closer
than I thought you were
I'm going to get some distance give me
that mine get get out of the
way really fumbling these
grabs at least they got plenty of
stamina as long as no one Visa
douche oh yeah I'm getting good oh yeah
oh
yeah oh yeah oh such good okay he's oh
he's just around the corner okay so I
can get the ticket over
here
oh come
on I'm just getting some extra money so
that I can
okay I got it where was the uh uh where
was the turny thing where's the tney
Style turny style oh boy okay that's not
good okay give me that turny style
where's where do I where do I go there
seems to be a bit of an issue here I
don't know where I go I
ah
don't you guys have places to be where
you think this is fun just wandering
around I have a ticket okay good
[Applause]
oh
oh Dash wait I could have dashed I do
kind of enjoy this I like the concept
conceptually it's very fun I think it's
different I think it's Unique and I
think that there's definitely some for
more here because it's just it's so
unsettling to have something just
walking after you
it's I think it's pretty cool I think it
should reset your uh your energy though
in between this level cuz otherwise it's
kind of a disadvantage what what does
the dash do just it just does nothing
and then drains your stamina that's all
it does hi does it change every time I
look or just when I lose sight of it cuz
that is fun cuz then you can get into
some elements of like okay but what what
is it is it just a tall dude or is there
is that the thing after you you know
look out behind you and what's in the
case what if I dash at
it oh all right that's pretty good
moving on welcome to boil noodles at
night that's
it
why do I have a picture of just a gun do
I have I think I think what I was going
to do you guys know this thumbnail right
okay for the I stole a condom animation
which is great and it's good originally
it
[Laughter]
was but this would have gotten
demonetized on YouTube extremely
fast so I had to change anyway back to
the game what are we boiling noodles a
night I can't sleep yet I have haven't
had my nudes maybe eating noodles will
make me sleepy and go to bed I want to
boil some noodles I hope there are still
some noodles left in the kitchen God I
love noodles I've never liked noodles
more did I tell you about my noodle
nightmare it's a it's a nightmare that
hearkens back to when I was a kid and I
had it recently and I remember it very
VI vividly involved my brain being
pulled out um if you want to know the
concept behind it you have to listen to
the distractable episode because I
talked about it when it happened it was
not good um Link in the description for
that just one noodle how was there just
one noodle this won't fill me up I want
to buy one more noodle all
right got to go get a
noodle this
is I think I'm in
Japan
oh I want to go right or do I I don't
really I don't I I swear I don't try to
be contrarian sometimes and I couldn't
go left anyway because it was an
invisible wall but sometimes I just
really want to be contrarian why is it
so dark why is the Ethereal Blackness
permeating the entire
neighborhood
uhhuh
see I don't know how some things manage
to do this where where even the simplest
thing like walking down the street can
be unsettling and it's hard to
encapsulate into words but sometimes it
can really
happen what is you're
fine you're a beautiful butterfly there
is nothing
wrong with your
face or
jaw
hi hi what do you want to buy noodles
sir
noodles the noodles are
[Music]
gone the
noodles okay thank you sir I feel
too
calm
hi
kind excuse
me it is odd how some things that can be
so simple seem
unsettling
so many times in games I go like what's
that behind me and then actually was
that
dude behind
me the noodles are gone well I want to
boil just
one I'll boil just one what a strange
house I don't like the timing of that
it's a strange house but I guess it is
my home so I guess I won't complain too
hard about that what's in here
peekaboo peekaboo who's pooping who's in
my
who's who's in there who's
pooping see I don't like
that I don't like
that why are there two noodles
here I don't care I want to cook it I
want to put water in the pot and boil
noodles I forgot to buy water there's no
water in my house
why
why what do you
mean what do you
mean I should really lock my
door
I hate this I hate this the game hasn't
even done anything actually the game's
done a lot by doing very little and
letting my mind fill the gaps give me
all your water hey you look dehydrated
you have any water so it's $1
okay thank you where's your friend
friend who the person before he said you
were his friend and live with
you I just live alone at home home and I
don't know him you live alone at
home yeah yes I'm new here I don't know
anyone
uh-huh hello can I help you
friend oh oh oh oh oh
oh you'll never catch me
oh okay I'mma go
now I got my eye on
you I don't know why I choose to walk
down the middle of the street shouldn't
I be on the sidewalk like a not psycho
person
[Music]
mayhaps
well that was unfortunate why did that
happen that is quite a
door anybody else here anybody else want
to play peekaboo Oh I thought I saw
something in the bed I'm going to make
these noodles now it's kind of been my
whole thing in life
I need noodles you're right I
do you will not get in the way of my
noodles
boiled boiled
boiled
what what who's there show
yourself all
right
[Music]
whatever
ding I need a chair to sit and eat
do I sure do don't
I even just getting why do I need to BR
this doesn't make any
sense where do I put it how do I put it
what do you mean what what is this what
what there I need to Plate I don't think
you really do kind of noodles are
these I need noodles and put them on the
plate I will take noodles and put them
on the
plate well it's time to eat
yum maybe if there is a Juice drink it
will look good and
better
want to eat it I guess I'm very hungry I
want to eat now and it's so late that
I'm tired of walking
there
yum
all right I'm done go to bed
now you eat noodles and your stomach is
very full and you sleep very well but
the next day your stomach
hurts what got three different what do
you mean what
what
what oh how long has that been able to
be
opened has there been more stuff that
could be
opened
uh-huh uh-huh I don't know about this
guys all right I want to go right I'm
going do this but um I don't uh I don't
know I don't know about I this anyway
how do I
run
oh why is that toggleable wait where' I
go oh why is that
toggleable hi
noodles
noodles oh nope goodbye later
[Laughter]
dude
dumb what two
noodles okay no water
huh you you you all you all
suck oh I smell a foul oh what what do
you mean what do what do you mean what
do what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean what
what do you mean what what do you what
do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean hi what do you
mean what do you mean what's with the
foul loader what's with the foul loader
what do you what do you smell what do
you what do you smell you smell
bad you you smelling bad I'm out of
here why would there have been a foul
odor can I go around the back no of
course
not I'm
cooking
who who are
you
oh well that's a
problem
oh
done all right I want to buy a
drink I don't know why did my typing get
all weird I'm going for
it you can't stop
me
hi want to buy something who are you
where is the man in the white shirt
him he's behind
you all
right hey wait wait a minute he wasn't
behind me at all
what
he's he's not behind me at all you
lied can I get a
drink you got a
drink you got to you got a
drink drink all right goodbye I guess I
don't get a
drink
oh
no well that's not
good
hey oh I was killed and made into a b
was like the previous
victim
uhhuh
flashlight I've had a flashlight this
whole
time why am I learning so many new
things I don't know how to get the last
ending I don't know what that would even
be oh wait
what you sleep when stove is on and your
house is on fire and your body is
scorched oh I found the oh ah well that
was boiled noodles at night I suppose I
got all the all three endings that's
pretty good
um good stuff can't fault
it boil noodles the night learned your
lesson don't do
it moving
on this is excuse me sir and this called
out to me because this was made by the
people that made faith I think and a
name that I haven't seen in a bit Jesse
Cox Polaris for life if anybody
remembers those days and then probably
these names are familiar and I believe
that I've seen Molly Moon's Tik toks
that are fundamentally similar to how
this game is presented which you will
see very soon it's not quite like analog
horror but it's not too distant from
analog horror my brother went missing a
few days ago I hope whoever lives here
can help me find him
oh here somebody comes now well that's
awfully convenient when I have missing
people in my life they do often run up
right to me hey who are
you you want to see my
flyer
oh uh-huh he looks familiar let's go
inside and ask my
friend okay um can your friend come out
here let me tell them you're here your
clothes are different meet Yourself by
home thanks thank you oh ah
oh
great what does the eyeball
do
okay
COA why does that look like a face up
there that's probably not
intentional probably
not that might be
intentional okay
oh okay
yeah
well this is a
problem hi they're in the basement
follow
me
um yeah okay go ahead how you down there
you know since we're both right here you
could uh meet me down there by going at
the same time and you first cuz it's
your home maybe don't worry I'll call
the sheriff
yea partner all
right what is this would you like a
screwdriver all
right would you like a screwdriver all
right well this is this is
lovely wait sorry no not lovely actually
you know I'm super nostalgic for an
unfinished basement
greetings we've been expecting
you would you like a screw driver all
right um what are you doing down here
well I already know that have you seen
my brother I don't believe I have we
could ask the other members if they have
though great but first we must
pray follow
me great
[Music]
as our newest member you'll have to
perform the
prayer you know what fine yeah I you
want screwdriver all right fine you know
I I ain't got no problem with this the
outline on the floor with a
screwdriver it's quite a
complex thing
would you like a screwdriver okay well
that's not what I meant um
so you know there were rumors that my
brother disappeared because of some
mysterious cult operating within our
very
neighborhood you guys wouldn't know
anything about that would you anyway you
guys get to see my incredible Mouse
skills we yippe we yippe how how
detailed am I supposed to make
this do I go through the center as
well good okay now you'll need to make a
sacrifice you a screwdriver all right
okay you know what I don't really have
any you you think that in this would be
a bit of a Choose Your Own Adventure
style thing where I have some options
but you know how it
be I'm going to do
it watch out watch out watch
out did it work did did it work oh boy I
hope oh oh
oh
okay
oh obviously I did it wrong you did it
wrong I know that I'm
aware G but
oh you screwed
her sorry I know I probably shouldn't be
laughing this much
but
well what's over here ah screwdriver all
right I'm pretty sure you would have
seen me go in
here oh
and I uh what is this why is that there
I don't know
um sure does give me a lot of
options do I not have the screwdriver
anymore I wish I could see what that
is
sure that's that's in the
way what happens if what if I just can I
oh I can't go back okay I wish that
wasn't
there
uh sure let's watch some
tube I don't feel like I should be this
free to
explore
H
oh that was too close I need to find a
way out of here I do
definitely
bathroom
uh-oh well I didn't know that I was
still running but I guess it makes sense
hey wait a
minute oh what's over here
bedroom oh wait no I've been
there probably not a good
idea
uhoh all
right ah ah
ah
oh ah this hole it was made for me looks
like the same hole that we went in in
the in heist in one of the endings you
remember that bet you do
oh
interesting um so I only got two of the
endings what would the other ending be
who are you can I use your phone come
inside oh okay now let's ask my friends
if they seen your brother no no not my
brother no it's not about my brother no
no no no no no no no it's not about my
brother why don't I call call the
sheriff and ask about your brother he's
a good friend of mine okay yeah but I I
never said anything about my bro
[Music]
um I'm waiting for you in the living
room come find me okay this is a little
different there's something different
here what's going on
hi don't mind
me don't don't don't mind
me weird none of these clothes look like
mollies I I don't remember telling me
her name none of them are her size or
her style I would know that I know that
real good whose clothes are these and
where are their
owners H you know it's a good point a
lot of good
points a lot of good points it's my
brother's ID well this seems conclusive
so he's here or at least he was but
where is he
now
uh like my
outfit no it's not your style and I know
that you can't fool me I know exactly
what's going on
here you steal clothes let's play uh a
dreame this game only has one
rule all right I always
win what what the [__] is the point of
playing the game
then what the [__] is the point of it if
you always win and nobody else can win
how is that fun for me anyway where'd
you get that back my friend gave it to
me let's ask him in the basement no
you're stubborn okay I like
that I'm spoken
for
what you know oh I remember what I
didn't do I know I know what I didn't
do
I know what happened I know what
happened take this all right take take
that all right let's uh
you for a prize
okay
[Music]
um
no oh yeah yeah right now you're your
prized I don't want it take the
screwdriver okay
well all right what's over here what's
over
[Music]
here that's probably
fine oh my god oh I don't know if I want
to be down here why would I want to be
down here God damn it this doesn't help
me at all we've been expecting you what
are you doing the likeminded group of
individuals but I don't they might know
something about my brother I could join
and earn their
trust no I'd like to see my brother I
don't believe I
have ask me of but first we must
pray I I feel like this I I don't I feel
like I feel like that I'm might to
skipped a step or seven all right how
about one of
these That's supposed to be a middle
finger it doesn't really look like it
but it's like okay it's like okay so
this is this is the the fingers are here
and you got your nails here and then and
then um you
know then you got your swirly
fingerprint there and you
know that's definitely a hand maybe some
shading will help here some of that that
help does that does this help or hinder
it hinders doesn't it it hinders okay
what about one of
these okay let's got some
hairs no really
okay
okay and then got the two bulbus that's
no longer a penis but you
know
good now all right hold on here did it
work oh
what oh
oh oops oh okay all right uh well this
is
going oh I'm done all right I want to
try this again just
because hold that thought all right the
shff will be here soon that's great I'm
happy about that come sit
down
okay how about some nice
tea like
gossip I made it myself
ah all
right I drugged you that's not
good okay and here we are my problem is
I'm too trusting that's that's what I am
that's that's what it is just too
trusting how about some
nice I made it my myself no thank you um
I've been so
lonely yeah me too without my
brother my missing brother which I guess
I haven't
mentioned okay I could use some
company want to go to my
room I thank you I'm bored let's go ask
my friend if they've seen your brother
they in the basement I thought you said
you were lonely so you
know I'll wait for how about some nice
tea I made it myself I'm not
thirsty I've been
so I could use some
company want to go to my
room okay give me a minute
ah I see this is just a way to walk
around ah so I don't think that there's
anything else
here to explore this did just say it was
a demo so I'm just going to assume that
there's some things missing or not
necessarily missing but it's like not
full although I don't know where else
this go besides you know Finding
brother like my outfit you it's funny
cuz we're in apparently your bedroom and
you'd think that your clothes would be
here yeah I don't think that there's
anything else here I'm pretty sure that
this is it cuz I I I've tried all of the
options and there doesn't seem to be
anything else so I think that's it it
just said three endings and you know
sometimes it's like three endings and
then a secret ending but I don't think
that's what it is okay I'm going to quit
it there then that was excuse me sir
demo here's my thoughts on this I'm not
going to say uh too much stuff critical
about it because now not that's not to
suggest that there's a lot critical to
say but the thing is I'm not sure what
it's trying to be because it's not
scary but then again I don't think it's
trying to be uh so I don't know enough
to really have an opinion on this cuz
I've never made a game before uh and I
always encourage people to go try and
make a game I would say that this one
does not set it up enough to be able to
expand it into a full one and the reason
I say that specifically is because this
says demo and so demo it's either going
to be a tech demo which is what I think
this can be judged as not that I'm
judging I don't want to judge anything
but as a tech demo I think that it it is
going if you were going to expand this
you'd have to start all over from the
beginning again it's just because the
thing set up here and because it's
liveaction footage continuity alone
would have to like expand some more and
this does feel like something like hey
let's just shoot something in in our
house and that's great I'm all about
that because that opens up so many
opportunities to just to have creative
fun with it and that's what I like about
this you know and this is why I can't
really judge it well I wouldn't judge it
but also like I don't think anybody can
really judge it because I don't think it
was super intended to be a scary
experience as opposed to just being like
a kind of odd quirky and surreal thing
that's what I'll say even though I
probably didn't say anything at all
there that of value which is usually how
my experience goes so thank you
hopefully you expand this to a full idea
and then um yeah I I mean I'm not OPP
post to this format it's basically a
Choose Your Own Adventure and I love
choose your own Adventures i' made a few
myself and I think that they have the
potential to be something really cool
and a vehicle for people to express
creativity in any circumstance which
this is just like yeah just a house
outside house live action stuff compile
into a game create some fun assets lock
in some sound design and then have some
fun so that's what it is and that's what
it could be and that's what anybody
could do so I encourage anybody out
there give that a
[Music]
try thank you
human your sacrifice will not
be I
will I will have my
VI